hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a
late-night drink oh my goodness you're
not the same as tiny box Tim get out of
here sorry I just had to do that okay
the moment I saw you down here I knew
you had gotten into the previous owners
stash of self-made wine a complete whack
job that guy was he used to use all
sorts of lucinda genetic substances
making the okay so it was pure LSD I had
planned to clear the cellar that junk
but thought it best to consult you first
luckily upon seeing you crawl around the
same hallway over and over I knew you
would drank one of the less dangerous
ones
some of those mixtures have some pretty
nasty effects nevertheless I locked the
cellar door to be safe and on your spare
key if you drop during your episode
behind this note once you've come to
your senses come on upstairs why do I
get the feeling that you're lying to me
mr. landlord okay didn't I have the
cellar door key before we're gonna fake
you one oh hey hi buddy
how are you doing your big inch uh your
big mouth is even bigger now I love it
deep into the darkness peering long I
stood there wondering fearing doubting
and grrrrrr Allan Poe Edgar Allan Poe oh
I'm back here again
who are you how did you get here I don't
even know where here is and why did a
damn Ames you'll try to kill me my
deepest apologies I feared you and one
of those monsters wearing a human guise
oh it's gonna be difficult tell me how
you got here I don't know where are you
where am i I am too broken to retain a
physical presence
any minute now please tell me what is
this place a sort of void between life
and death
avoid these doors where do they lead
okay my time spent here has broken my
mind those doors lead to the shattered
fragments of my psyche how do I get out
of this place now I believe that if my
mind were to be restored I could help
you alright so I just go into these
rooms and get your head back in order
that sounds simple deceptively so each
fragment contains a piece of my mind my
memories my thoughts my fears they will
shape each room some may not be safe it
seems I like I don't have it all come on
then hurry
you being here seems to be accelerating
my degradation which room should I go in
first it doesn't matter though only a
few are open I've kept the rest closed
for safety work on the ones that are
open and I'll get the rest open the
signs above the doors will tell where
each leads well then all right okay oh
that's so cool it's like a hub and I can
choose my own adventure all this cuz I'm
sorry inviting Lou you know they mmm
childhood mmm childhood her love I'm
gonna take the love path if you know
what I mean baby haha maybe I'll see
that lovely angel again whoa ah ah it's
so nice this seems to be someone
somebody else waiting on the bus who's
Vincent is Vincent the guy which way do
I go I can't go wait one oh okay hey are
you waiting for the bus - yes
oh sorry if I found it creepy just so
you know I'm not a serial killer
anything hahahaha that's that's good to
know if I was I probably wouldn't look
like I do not that I know what a serial
killer looks like haha I'm an idiot
so this is what love is like meeting on
a bus type totally creeping out a lady
looks like that girl from before is at
the bus stop
let me just sneak up behind her and and
and do stuff hi there
oh hello again I guess meeting here
doesn't bode well for mine not a serial
killer status yeah I'll have to keep my
eye on you
what Oh uh-huh I didn't get your name oh
wait what the hell I'm Vincent hello
you're going to fat what but arm what
nothing
okay so this is what love is like I
guess oh now it's raining Dan it wasn't
supposed to rain today
so says who the weatherman of 1824 are
you all right I really don't like the
water now notice how your batter
anything I just don't like the water
are you made of sugar or something I
know what are you crazy or something I
just you can stand out of my umbrella if
you want hey hey thank you very much
Anna huh it's my day oh it's nice what
made you change your mind hey Jerry was
still out on your silly real killer
status I see who is a verdict I don't
think a serial killer one could be
afraid of water Jason Voorhees was yeah
you really are an idiot aren't you that
seems to be how things work for me yeah
when did it happen when did I become an
idiot I don't know no I get the feeling
that's genetic I'm talking about the
hydrophobia yeah I almost drowned it a
child oh I'm sorry it's all right oh I
see the bus ha well it was nice to see
you again you too
dammit Winton make a move stab her in
the bud not like that this is my spare
room Bella you can have it if you walk
home with me sure hey you what do I
sound like scooby-doo when I'm Vincent
huh
most people who know me are aware I have
a certain phobia of water but when I met
you oh when I met you you sheltered me
from the storm
both the real one and the one in my head
when I'm with you I'm not afraid anymore
you offer me protection from the rain
and I promise to show you everyday that
even though I may be prone to childish
fears I love you more than anything the
world I'll stab you in the blood for the
rest of my days this is a tender moment
guarded by these angelic baby statues
not baby statues but Hello Baby statues
Oh what's up
oh okay my god that was cheesy I never
knew I could be guilty of so much
hyperbole hyperbole I'm such an idiot
well you're my idiot I think it's cute
when you I didn't get the rest of that
oh oh that was it I have another piece
so far your memories have been rather
happy how did you wind up in a place
like this
I can't remember I imagine the same way
you did hopefully these fragments will
help us suppose figure that but I
haven't been anywhere else yet am I
supposed to go to the childhood place
first is that what I was supposed to do
oh well whatever let's go baby
literally baby I think oh look at me oh
don't leave your room for the rest of
the night
his most childhood memories being
grounded can't blame him we got into
plenty of trouble back at the orphanage
oh I used to be an orphanage oh hello
oh trying to hide from me hey Weldon get
I want that yo-yo closet key oh okay
all right then fine by me can't hide
anything from mr. markiplier m2 Pro what
is this go take shirts from the closet
okay Oh God bro all right what am I
doing with it got a broken badminton
thing tennis racket babbit
no violin from Justine that music sure
is delightful anything hiding in the
bookshelf is that new nope okay so I got
a key I bet what was that who's that ha
ha ha what is this a dagger do I get a
dagger as a little kid what am i okay I
bet there's something up here way they
hide keys come on give me some give me
some
no all right then fine be that way when
I said something about the window or I
don't know I didn't catch all of it that
one's blocked up anything here here here
said I got the shirts I don't know what
that means though I think I'm supposed
to try to get out the window baby baby
baby I can't touch the window at all so
what am I supposed to do
no tinderboxes anything in the fire you
think around the fire
anything up above the fire oh hello baby
how you doing well ain't you just a tiny
baby baby yeah wait can i I know all
right there's got to be a way to get up
somewhere because I'm a little kid if I
was a little kid everything would be hid
up higher so there might be something up
there let me actually better view from
up here
OOP whoo I love this everything's just a
little bit bigger it's so adorable it's
over not scary but I mean it's still
cool I like it okay
do I see anything important I'm supposed
to am I supposed to like late meant for
cutting him wait a minute I have a blade
did I Oh what if I was supposed to cut
up the shirts or something but I don't
see him anymore so to cut the rope no oh
what am I supposed to do oh oh man that
I I didn't even think of that now I
don't know how that helped me but I got
that I guess well what does that do for
me can I go out the window now did I get
everything I needed what do you want
from me game I'm guy I'm guy that's what
I am I'm guy hello baby you want to help
me get out of here because I can't seem
to understand what it wants from me baby
baby help me out here give me a little
love I've already been to the love place
I've mastered it wait a minute
nope that was wrong baby I'll be right
here I've been wandering forever
baby baby baby
goddamn it oh alright okay whatever I
someone send the comments before that
that these were kind of ridiculously
hidden okay whatever I got it you know
I've been wandering around for about 15
minutes straight trying to find what I'm
supposed to do Oh can't use that item
that way well what am I supposed to do
break out the window that's what you
said way before oh my oh I needed a
crowbar to tear down the yeah it's okay
it's all right I'm okay I'm all right so
uh this last step no object to use it on
great you're gonna break the [ __ ] out of
these whoa what the
what are you kid ah Omega to break up
the windows are you kidding me that
wasn't so hard they will not all be that
simple
[ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you
so I gather you're Vincent and anti
would seem so my memories still foggy at
best but finding those pigs seems to be
helping and are you are Anna yes I stole
my memory so it seems as long as I'm
here have lost my memories pertaining to
Vincent well isn't that just delightful
delightfulness true love at its finest
I'm done with this part I'm very upset
now go one more I'll go one more so long
as it doesn't take me forever humor
really joy humor and joy oh let's go for
a humor I could use a laugh right now
give me something funny
oh just a life oh oh good blood
very funny hilarious blood you know what
whatever I'm just gonna Tom my tits
oh look storage key does that go in here
or what no oh wait a minute
what hi I miss my do didn't I what did
you maybe I don't know move back here so
I kiss you I jump-scare hahaha I think
the door is stuck
really oh I know everyone hates me
you think I chose this I didn't want to
be this guy originally auditioned to be
a grunt they said I wasn't naked enough
I mean how is that even possible
haha look I think I'll just stay in here
just go ahead and leave please oh I'm
sorry do you want to be a flow high in
memory hahaha yeah oh my god cuz I'm
sorry you've redeemed yourself in my
eyes oh come on come on you can fly your
naked giblets at me I'll accept it okay
fine so this custom story is suddenly
amazing again it went from being awful
cuz I was wandering with that run for 15
minutes but now it's totally amazing I
loved it I loved every second of it okay
so this is this is back in the beginning
and one of these got to be the storage
there we go okay ah well then excuse me
hi you gonna scare me or is this all
gonna be comedy that guy getting scary I
like this guy is that a bite is that a
butt is that a bite there's a pregnancy
there's a partner thing there is okay
never mind there's gonna bite in the
chest it's a chest but chest but okay
now I'm getting this is a chest but I
forgot about my lantern chest boy
no no one's free gonna hello hi what are
you doing you're just gonna look at the
wall there all right finally be that way
bro um the reason for coming in there
there's got to be another exceptionally
well hidden key right I'm right aren't a
dick give me your key are you doing
taking a piss on the wall smash smash
smash is it under the but it's an under
debt but that is okay anyway oh ah right
in plain sight you got all really really
really hahaha you bastard you slimy
bastard
oh you some other oh hey hey buddy what
are you doing there hi bye yeah oh he
keeps pissing me off and then redeeming
himself although that cue was kind of my
fault I was looking in the very hidden
places instead of the not hidden places
this key is a strange smell hmm oh my
god I am laughing my ass off
oh I'm laughing my ass off and it went
through that chest over there Oh what do
we got what do we got what have we got
nothing oh oh there we go
hi what are you doing what are you doing
buddy
whoa whoa
oh it's a migrant oh my god oh my god
this is amazing
hi big one hi big guy how are you doing
you're doing good you look good back
there look good you look real good oh my
god I love it oh my god I love it
oh hi how are you doing oh can I go in
there oh I can't oh look at it
oh I love it so much I love it so much I
love you and I love all of you
okay all right am I supposed to move on
I'm guessing super fun oh no it's not
done yet
oh okay oh there we go a rose a rose
with twice as many thorns would be twice
as lovely I don't know either way I got
a key oh that's so cool I love it I love
it I want to squeeze it to death
ah oh it's darkness oh ah that's not
real that's a lie you're just making me
think that's real it's not real hello oh
hi I'm from tech support I'll fix this
up for you
that'll be 600 failures you have a very
odd sense of humor I had to deal with
this sense of humor for years I hate
both of you oh I love it I think I'm Way
over time for this part but either way I
don't care I love it
I love this custom story I love it to
death I don't care about the key trouble
I add I love it I love it okay anyway so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you my
voice in the next video
you